[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ايه الاخبار عاملين ايه طيب
حاضر انا موط جدا ان انا معاكم
النهارده مين بيرن دلوقتي جماعه مش
المفروض تعملوا موبايلكم
الو ايوه حاضر انا في بنت
طيب
ايوه خص طيب واكلم افتح المايك يا عم لا
يا عم افتح
المايك حدود ما خلصنا من الحدود بقى يا
عم ماشي حاضر هخلص واروح عشان عندي ثانويه
عامه وعندي مذاكره ولازم اجيب مجموع
حاضر طيب
حاضر والله خلا عرفت ان لازم اجيب مجموعه
ماينفعش اعمل حاجه تانيه
حاضر ماشي سلام
ماشي بنسمع س الحدود دايما ماعرفش هي ليه
منعرفش دايما بنتحمل غريب جدا دايما
يقوللك لازم تحط نفسك في زون معينه ثانويه
عامه يلا ذاكر عشان تنجح عشان تجيب مجموعه
عشان تخش مش عارف ايه يلا في جامعه تقدير
بس ماينفعش حاجه تانيه تجي بعد الجامعه
يلا بقى الوظيفه يلا الجواز يلا مش عارف
ايه ماذا بعد
احنا بنحط في حدود كبيره جدا كل يوم واحنا
مش واخدين بالنا ليه المشكله ديت ليه
دايما الناس بتحطله في الازمه ديت بشكل
غير طبيعي ليه دايما الواحد المفروض ان هو
يواجه مشاكل ان هو محطوط في زون صغيره جدا
ما ينفعش ان هو يبدع فيها خالص هي دي
المشكله اللي احنا هنتكلم عنها النهارده
مشكلتي اصلا الاساسيه ان الحدود بتتحط لنا
بناء على الاعمار السنيه يعني انت مثلا في
ابتدائي واعدادي يلا انت هتذاكر بس عشان
عشان انت المفروض تتفوق مش مهم هتطلع ايه
المهم ان انت تتفوق وخلاص اخلص اخش ثانويه
عامه انت لازم تتفوق بشكل معين عشان تجيب
المجموع الفلاني عشان تبقى زي ابن خالتك
برض اخلص جامعه برض بيتقال لي نفس الجمله
لحد دلوقتي انا خص افتكرت ان انا خلص
ثانويه عامه وخلاص كده هخش بقى الجامعه بى
براحتي واشتغل واشوف انا عايز اعمل ايه لا
برض هتحط في نفس الزون ولا برض انت مطالب
ان انت تجيب تقدير عشان تجيب الوظيفه اللي
مش عارف فين وماذا بعد وهكذا وهكذا وهكذا
انا جاي اتكلم عن الحدود بكذا شكل انا مش
جاي اتكلم بشكل اللي هو لا اسعى وخلاص
والجو ده لا خالص انا جاي اتكلم بشكل
مختلف جزء العلم النفس اصلا بيتكلم عنه
وبيقول دايما عن فكره الحدود اللي احنا
حطينا لنفسنا ان انت لما ما بتبقاش واثق
من نفسك وتبقى شايف دايما قدراتك ان انت
على قدك لا ما تطلعش تتكلم قدام الناس اصل
انت ممكن تغلط اصل الناس مش هتركز معاك
اصل الناس مش هتسقف لك تيجي بعدها تركز في
الجزء الثقافي طب الجزء الثقافي ده جا
منين
لو جينا ركزنا ان احنا من 50 سنه هتلاقي
جدك وعمك بيقولوا نفس الكلام اللي بيتقال
لك دلوقتي من اهاتك واهاتك اللي هو نفس
الفكره بتاعه الحدود اللي انت بتحج لنفسك
امشي جنب الحيط ما تعملش حاجه تانيه نفس
الجزء في الجزء العملي انا اخدت كورس اي
سي دي ال خلاص كده انا بقيت اعرف استخدم
الكمبيوتر كويس جدا انا مش اعمل حاجه
تانيه نفس الجزء برض في الجزء الاجتماعي
اللي بينتقل كل من كل تراث للتاني اعرف
يعني مثلا لما نيجي نشوف القبائل اللي في
الهند هتلاقي منهم لحد دلوقتي
بيدفنوا الناس عن طريق الحرق مش بيدفنوا
ههم بيحرقهم مفيش عندهم تجديد للتراث وده
اللي هيخلينا نتكلم على الجزء اصلا اللي
هو القوس العصبي اللي بينقل اصلا الحدود
بالنسبه لك بتتكون ازاي اصلا فانت بتاخد
رده الفعل من اي حد تبدا ان هي تحولها
لاستجابات بناء كمان على خبرتك السابقه وع
التجارب السابقه اللي كانت عندك تبدا بقى
تكون يلا انا مش عمل حاجه تانيه اللي هي
او اللي هي الذات المحدده عقلك بيقوللك
انت تركز في ده وبس ماينفعش ان انت تعمل
حاجه تانيه انت ما تقدرش ان انت تكون فائق
الحدود انا هنا مش جاي اتكلم عن صاحب
بالين مش كذاب او صاحب بالين مش لاثه انا
مش جاي اتكلم عن الكلام ده كله خالص انا
جاي اتكلم عن فكره تانيه ان احنا دايما
بنحط نفسنا في زون ممكن احنا نكون اصلا
مختلفين عنها احنا ربنا خلق لنا الانعام
وخلق لنا الارض وسخرها لنا ان هي تكون ان
احنا نعيش فيها ونتمتع بكل حاجه فيها فانت
تقدر ان انت تعمل اكتر من حاجه في نفس
الوقت يمكن انا راحه المجتمع اللي انا كنت
فيه كان شجعني شويه ودعمني هم امي واخواتي
واصحابي كانوا اكتر ناس بصراحه بيدعمني بس
انا هنا مش جايه اوصل للناس اللي بيعملوا
ده انا جاي اوصل للناس اللي م عندهمش ده
لو انت م عندكش المجتمع اللي يدعمك ويقدر
ان هو يطلعلك الك الكوميونتي اللي يقدر
يدعمك وسبورت الافكار اللي عندك وسبورت
فكره ان انت تقدر ان انت تتوسع في كذا
حاجه انت تقدر ان انت تعمل ده مع نفسك
تقدر تخلق لنفسك الحاجه اللي تخليك انت
يونيك في نفسك ومميز مش لازم تسعى ورا ان
حد يقول لك حاجه نحل مشكله الحدود دي ازاي
عن طريقه اكتر من حاجه حبيت اجمع لكم كل
الافكار اللي انتوا سمعتوها النهارده ا في
الكا فكره دول نتطوع حاول على قد ما تدر
تتطوع وتشوف ناس جديده تسافر تعرف على
ثقافات مختلفه تقدر كمان ان انت تطور من
نفسك ومهاراتك انا دايما مقتنع بمقوله
حلوه جدا وكل مره هقولها واي مره هطلع في
اي ستيج او في اي مكان هفضل اقولها خذ من
كل علم شيء وخذ من علم واحد كل شيء لازم
دايما تتعلم تكون مثقف وعندك وعي باللي
حواليك يعني اشهر حاجه احنا بنمر بيها
دلوقتي اخواتنا واهالينا وهم بيتعاملوا مع
ولاد العم برده حطين لهم نفس الحدود لا
اصلهم هيعملوا ايه طبعا انتوا فاهمين انا
بتكلم بالنبره دي ليه يعني او بتكلم
باللغه دي ليه فلا احنا نقدر احنا عددنا
مش قليل احنا نقدر نكون مجتمع قوي ولا
يضيع حق وراهم مطالب طبعا زي ما قلت لكم
في حاجات كتيره جدا تقدر تخرج بيه من فكره
الحدود والقوقعه اللي انت بتحطها لنفسك
ولكن ماقدرش ازود اكتر من انت لازم تسعى
وتجتهد
وشكرا
[تصفيق]
لكم